there they are friend follow me  oh gosh sorry Frank sorry strong form  my name is Dr Lily Houghton my brother  and I are looking for passage upriver  what's out there in the jungle it's not  a fun vacation well I'm not here for a  vacation Legend has it that there is a  tree that possesses unparalleled healing  power it will change medicine forever  and you need someone to help you find it  here will you go  sometimes it just needs a bit of a  nobody touches my engine but me  what did I just do  there you go  we're gonna do this together  haven't you been dreaming about  Adventure  you're chasing after some far-fetched  idea  the thing that you see wants to kill you  and can  [Music]  you wanna turn back nope just getting  started  on my own bed  [Music]  oh my gosh  illusion  torpedo Mike  foreign  [Applause]